So if someone fundamentally alters the course of your life, pulling you out of absolute ignorance and giving you a clear direction, how do you thank them?
Because for most of us, sending a polite message or just offering a heartfelt verbal acknowledgement is the default.
It feels sufficient.
But we are unpacking a source that argues a verbal thank you is entirely inadequate.
We're exploring a text that refuses to treat gratitude as just a fleeting feeling and instead demands we view it as a legally binding debt.
Welcome.
We're the Master and the Disciple by Jafar ibn Mansur.
A 10th century dialogue that opens by asking how a person thanks a teacher for three gifts at once.
The call, the knowledge, the practice.
My final duty is similar to my initial duty.
And what we have in front of us is a text that tackles A load-bearing question about gratitude.
We are shifting gratitude entirely away from good manners.
We're going to establish exactly what it means to be indebted to a teacher and mechanically how that debt must be paid in full.
Yeah, the author sets the scene brilliantly at the very opening of the book.
So seekers arrive at the door of the master and they haven't come to passively consume more information.
Instead, they stand there and acknowledge 3 outstanding debts they already owe him.
First, their gratitude for his having called them to the true religion.
Second, their gratitude for the knowledge he pointed them toward.
And third, their gratitude for the religious practices he commanded them to perform.
But before they ask him for any new material, they ask him for the proper etiquette of asking.
Wait, the etiquette of asking.
Yes.
They want to know the strict obligations of a seeker in his mode of questioning.
Which shows they recognize that the transmission of knowledge isn't a casual exchange.
I mean, the asking itself has rules that must be respected.
Exactly.
And this points to a fundamental premise in this tradition.
Gratitude is not just a courtesy you owe to a benefactor.
It is a transaction of spiritual enlargement.
Spiritual enlargement.
Yeah, the tradition frames gratitude as something that actively expands the soul of the one who is grateful.
The Quran sets this principle plainly in chapter 14, verse 7, stating that if you are grateful, you will be increased in favor.
And again, in chapter 31, verse 12, it states that whoever is grateful is grateful for the good of his own soul.
So it's not about returning a favor.
It is about what the act of gratitude does to the structural architecture of your own spirit.
Wait, I struggle with that framing.
How so?
Well, if I receive a gift and I genuinely, from the bottom of my heart, offer a sincere verbal expression of gratitude, why isn't that enough?
Calling thanks a transaction or deed makes it sound incredibly cold.
I mean, if the feeling of appreciation is sincere, why must thanks be classified as a binding physical action?
To understand why the feeling alone is insufficient, we have to pause and define a concept that the author highlights at the very outset.
And that concept is comportment.
Comportment.
Let's unpack that together, because usually when we hear that word, we just think of having good manners or sitting up straight.
Right, but it's far heavier than good manners.
Comportment is functionally the force that opposes your own ego and desire.
Opposing the ego.
Exactly.
It's the disposition that structures every act of worship as a form of self-surrender.
Because the ego naturally wants to center itself to consume without restriction.
So comportment is the physical and mental training ground designed to prefer the other over the self.
Prioritizing the other is the only mechanism that draws a person out of the traps of egocentricity.
We are designed for the task of service.
and comportment is how we practice that service.
So comportment is the physical manifestation of surrendering your ego to something greater.
Yes.
Consider the comportment of eating.
The whole process is designed to respect and prioritize that sustenance over your own self, to physically humble your ego in relation to the blessing you're receiving.
The prophet, peace and blessings of Allah be upon him and his family, said, sit before your food like a servant sits before his master.
That makes perfect sense.
Humbling the self before the gift.
Honoring the gift of food requires physical humility.
You know, you cover your head, you use your right hand, you adopt the physical posture of a servant because without that sustenance,
The human being degrades to a mere animal state.
Precisely.
And if we carry that comportment from the table directly to the door of the master, the logic holds up.
The seekers are receiving the sustenance of knowledge.
The gift has been given.
Humbling the self before that particular life-saving gift demands something far heavier than just saying the right words.
It demands a deed.
Which brings us to the Master's actual answer to the seekers.
He doesn't simply give them a list of polite phrases to recite.
He answers their question about gratitude with a profound metaphysics of stages.
He tells them that for every beginning, there has been placed within it an end.
For every end, there is a goal.
And each goal has a limit whose full extent cannot be attained.
Okay, that sounds incredibly dense.
Walk me through what that actually means mechanically for someone who is just trying to say thank you for a gift.
It means that a divine gift is not a static object you can just put
on a shelf and admire.
A true gift is dynamic.
It's A trajectory.
You are given a beginning, which is the initial call, but that beginning naturally points to an end, which is the acquisition of knowledge.
Acquiring knowledge, however, is not the finish line.
It points to a goal, which is putting that knowledge into practice.
And that goal stretches out toward an infinite limit of spiritual perfection that you can travel toward, but never fully exhaust.
Okay, so the seeker is being told that the gifts themselves are arranged inside an active sequence.
The shape of the gift is literally a road, and therefore your gratitude must match the shape of the gift.
You cannot thank a road with a word.
You thank a road by walking it.
Exactly.
The master then breaks down the spiritual path of walking that road into 3 distinct stages, trial,
then right guidance, and finally piety.
Let's examine those three stages, starting with the initial stage, trial.
What is the mechanism of this trial?
The trial occurs because the unrefined self naturally rebels like a wild horse.
The ego gets in the way, pushing the seeker toward what the self desires rather than what is demanded by the divine order.
The ego views itself as the center of the universe, and it is entirely resistant to being tamed or directed by an outside authority.
The compiler of aphorisms, the commander of the faithful, peace be upon him, names that resistance precisely when he says the most disabling of ignorance is a man's ignorance of his own soul.
Oh, absolutely.
If you've ever tried to build a new habit and found yourself aggressively self-sabotaging on day three, you have experienced exactly what this text is describing.
You cannot walk the road if you are willfully ignorant of the mechanism inside you that actively refuses to walk.
Exactly.
The trial is the friction of confronting your own resistance.
But once the seeker succeeds in taming that ego, they enter the middle state, which is guidance.
This is where the friction begins to lessen.
They find direction and actually start to experience the profound benefits of the path.
And that leads directly to the final stage, piety.
How does the text define piety here?
Because that is another term that often gets reduced to just looking incredibly religious.
Piety here is a constant, deep-rooted awareness of the divine in absolutely everything the seeker does.
The mechanism that helps the seeker
through all three of these stages, moving them from friction to awareness is remembrance.
Remembrance.
Yeah, remembrance is repeated constantly until it becomes a second pulse.
By continuously bringing the divine to the forefront of your mind, you actively rewire your habits.
You stop reacting to the world through the defensive lens of your ego and start responding through continuous spiritual awareness.
So only after establishing this massive metaphysical framework, the road, the stages, the resistance of the ego, does the master finally give the practical answer to the seeker's original question.
They asked how to thank him for the call, the knowledge, and the practice.
Yes, and his answer permanently binds gratitude to action.
He tells them that showing gratitude to the scholar for the call is achieved through obeying him.
Gratitude for the knowledge is achieved by turning it into action and calling others to it, and gratitude for the right practice is achieved by striving.
driving patiently in it, being entirely consistent with it.
You can see the doctrine solidified here.
The father of imams summarizes this equation flawlessly.
Knowledge without action is a tree without fruit.
Okay, I have to push back on that first requirement.
You say gratitude for the call is obedience, but I don't buy that yet.
That sounds like wordplay.
How is obedience practically any different from a polite, respectful acknowledgement of the teacher's authority?
Obedience still just sounds like a mental posture of respect to me.
It is entirely different
from a mental posture.
Think of a doctor who prescribes A life-saving medication for a severe illness.
You can sit in the clinic and offer the doctor the most sincere, poetic praise for their medical brilliance.
You can acknowledge their authority completely, but praising the doctor will not cure your illness.
Oh, I see where you're going.
What cures you is doing exactly what the doctor prescribes, consistently for the prescribed duration.
You have to take the dose at the correct times.
You cannot stop taking it just because you start to feel a little better.
And you absolutely cannot skip the bitter doses.
All right, I concede the argument.
You have me there.
Acknowledging the doctor's authority with words changes absolutely nothing in your physical body.
Action is the only honest form of gratitude, and the only honest action is doing exactly what the giver prescribed, especially when the prescription is difficult.
My final duty is similar to my initial duty.
So if true gratitude requires this intense, continuous action, what does that actually look like out in the real world?
Because to answer that, the author grounds this heavy doctrine in specific narrative.
We are introduced to a seeker from Persia.
Right.
The author describes a man with a rich heart, a brilliant intellect, and a decent
education.
But despite all of his immense intellectual capacity, he's entirely subject to the trials of spiritual ignorance.
In fact, his ignorance heavily outweighs his knowledge.
He has a burning thirst for truth, but he completely lacks direction.
He's restless and suffering in the heat of this thirst.
And this leads us to one of the most vital and haunting images in the text.
The scholar is crossing a desert.
He suffers from a burning thirst, and he assumes the glimmering on the horizon is the reflection of water.
He runs desperately toward the mirage.
He arrives and there's absolutely no water.
Just sand.
He sees another shimmer in the distance, runs to that, and again, nothing.
He chases mirage after mirage.
But the crucial detail is what happens at the end of this exhaustion.
The seeker arrives at the exact point where the mirage is resolved into the absolute nothing it always was.
And it is at that exact point of nothing, at the absolute bottom of his profound disappointment, that he made to Allah and pays his account in full.
That is an interesting visual.
But why does the divine encounter only happen at the point of nothing?
Why doesn't he find enlightenment at an oasis?
Because as long as he believed the mirage was water, he was still relying on his own illusions.
He was still letting his ego dictate his reality.
The absolute exhaustion of his false hopes is the necessary prerequisite for true clarity.
He had to be broken of his reliance on his own flawed perception.
It's tearing down the ego completely.
Exactly.
And this motif is entirely deliberate.
The author is mirroring scripture.
The exact same picture is used in the chapter of Light, verse 39, describing deeds that are like a mirage in a desert, where the thirsty one thinks it is water until he comes to it and finds it nothing but finds the divine there and has paid his account in full.
Paul Walker, a modern historian, observes that this scholar's biography is deliberately framed by revelation.
The personal anecdote is operating as a direct paraphrase of scripture.
Walker frames it perfectly.
So through a teacher who finds him astray in this desert of exhaustion, the veil is finally removed from his intellect.
His thirst is satisfied with true knowledge.
And the text notes that through this intense metamorphosis, he becomes a dweller of Sinai.
We are talking about a geography of the soul here, not a physical map.
He moves from a state of chasing endless illusions to the mountain where revelation and absolute clarity are received.
His guidance is completed.
He is successfully saved from the desert.
And here is my final point of friction with this text.
The scholar has been saved.
He has crossed the desert.
He has confronted the crushing emptiness of the mirage, and he has finally found enlightenment.
Why can he not simply rest in that peace?
Why is he immediately placed under a massive crushing debt to leave that hard-won piece and go teach?
Because of the interior monologue that immediately follows his enlightenment,
the scholar begins to examine his own soul using a very specific logical sequence.
First, he recalls a proverb repeated by his spiritual father, the most excellent of deeds is giving life to the dead.
Giving life to the dead.
Yes, and in the settled reading of this proverb, giving life to the dead means imparting knowledge to the ignorant because the ignorant person is spiritually indistinguishable from a corpse.
A corpse is completely inanimate to the reality around it.
So the dead in this proverb are not those who explicitly refuse the call.
The dead are simply the ignorant who don't even know they're asleep, but who can still be raised if someone is willing to do the work.
Exactly.
The scholar looks at himself and realizes, I used to be dead and my master gave me life.
I was ignorant and he gave me knowledge.
He knows he isn't the first person to be ignorant, nor will he be the last.
then he asks himself a decisive, inescapable, counterfactual question.
He thinks about the origin of this divine affair, how it descended from the heavenly host to the creatures of this lower world, passing through many intermediaries, the first passing it to the second, the second passing it to the third.
And he asks himself, did this entire unbroken chain of transmission rip through the veil just for me?
Did it pass through the heavenly host and down through every single intermediary?
just so I could sit here, enjoy my personal enlightenment and be its final endpoint.
The answer is obviously no.
He realizes that the people who transmitted the knowledge before him earned their elevated status precisely by doing the grueling work of teaching him.
Their historical precedence does not relieve him of the burden to act.
The logic of the chain is absolute.
The first to receive the trust was duty bound to pass it on.
So is the second, and so is this scholar.
This connects so deeply to the broader tradition.
The father of Imam states, whoever teaches me a single letter has made me his servant.
The entire system runs on servitude.
It runs entirely on the debt owed by the receiver.
You don't just take the knowledge and go on a permanent spiritual vacation.
You are now a servant to the one who taught you.
And the only way to mathematically pay that debt forward is to become the master for someone else.
The structural symmetry demands it.
The scholar's realization is complete.
He must transmit the knowledge.
He cannot remain where he is.
So what does he actually do?
He travels.
He leaves his people, his comforts, and his possessions entirely behind.
He sets out among the Arab and non-Arab tribes.
He spends his days scrutinizing their faces, looking for any sign of spiritual aptitude.
He poses religious questions to test them, searching desperately for the one who is ready to receive the heavy trust he is carrying.
But he finds no response.
He finds no response.
He meets no seeker.
He continues to walk until he reaches the furthest part of the river country.
He is at the far edge of the inhabited world.
He has crossed continents, carrying this immense heavy trust, and he has not yet found the one human being for whom that trust will be released.
My final duty is similar to my initial duty.
We have looked closely at how gratitude cannot be a mere word.
It must be a deed.
We have seen how the gift is not a static object, but a road that must be walked.
And we have seen how the reception of true knowledge places an inescapable debt upon the receiver to pass it on.
So turn this inward.
Look at your own life.
Which of the three gifts that you have already received, the call, the knowledge, or the practice, have you answered purely with polite words rather than action?
And what would it actually cost you this week to begin the deed instead?
Because if you're still just saying thank you without walking the road, it makes you wonder, when you are finally ready to act, will the teacher you need even recognize you?
Or are they out there right now passing you by because you still look like part of the mirage?
Consider the scholar at the far edge of the world, still walking, his disciples still unfound.